bien comme vous êtes boxeur vous
comprendrez qu'on fasse une interview
dernier coup personne ne bouge pas en
djing
bien interview dernier coup votre
dernier coup dur j'en ai pas en mauvaise
voie
non je professe perdu la mémoire avec
tout ça non ouais je profiterai peut
être un peu de mémoire way le dernier
coup de tête j'ai acheté jeunes ont fait
d'eux non non vous n'êtes pas avec les
filles je vois blanchit donc c'est pas
du tout bon
dernier coup de coeur ma femme et puis
ma petite fille dans les coups de poing
dans les coûts de pont
or si moi j'étais sur un ring dans la
vie tant vantée bien non je reste dans
la vie on possède beaucoup pensent
qu'une claque up se bat ça c'est sympa
s'est effectué un dernier coup de gueule
il n'ya pas longtemps à ya pas longtemps
on m'a enlevé ma voiture dans une dans
la fois hier mouvement voiture et celle
à bord
les mecs qui touche attaqué son compte
dernier coup de rouge
bon là je vende décembre ouais je bute
sur le poteau se sent pas la pareille
larry coup de poker à las vegas
ah oui quand vous jouez au poker à las
vegas huawei derniers coups de feu non
non non jamais jamais non je t'ai riquet
sincérité en même temps dans les coups
de blues donner coup de blues
beaucoup bouche quand j'ai perdu mon
argent oui ça 10 millions d'entrées nerv
dernier coup de rein pour longtemps hier
soir madame non j'ai pas le temps ta
famille tu n'envoies moi j'ai pas le
temps ah ouais